president joe biden came to japan to
bolster one of the us's most important
alliances in the asia pacific at a time
of multiple challenges across the region
but he may have worsened one of those
regional flash points with less than
tactful answers at the main news
conference as he's done in the past
it came in response to a question about
whether the u.s would respond militarily
to a chinese invasion to take the island
of taiwan that beijing regards as a
breakaway territory are you willing to
get involved militarily to defend taiwan
if it comes to that yes
you are
that's the commitment we made
the u.s stance on taiwan has been far
more ambiguous in the past and the white
house immediately had to release a
statement trying to clarify the u.s
position but what sounded like a threat
to china brought this response
the taiwan issue is purely china's
internal affair which won't stand for
any foreign interference issues bearing
on china's core interests including the
sovereignty and territorial integrity
there is no room for compromise or
concession no one should underestimate
the chinese people's firm resolution
this has turned into something of a
distraction in what is meant to be a
strong show of unity against russian
aggression and also against increasing
military threats from china as well as
increased missile testing from north
korea as the only nation to have been
subjected to an atomic attack japan is
deeply concerned by north korea's
development of its nuclear arsenal but
it's also troubled by the increasing
assertiveness of china with ongoing
territorial disputes in the east china
sea
as a major power china has significant
responsibilities also in the economic
field to live up to that responsibility
i think it is important for japan to
work with the united states to encourage
china to fulfill its responsibilities in
accordance with international rules i
think such attitudes are important
biden has also used the trip to launch
the indo-pacific economic framework an
initiative aimed at safeguarding and
developing production of critical
commodities like advanced semiconductors
and setting universal standards for
labor and environmental protection
it's very very clear that from america's
perspective china is now the biggest
competitor on all fronts and as a result
of that what america is doing now is
building alliances across the world this
visit will culminate in a summit meeting
of the leaders of the so-called quad
security alliance led by the u.s and
seen as a further attempt to constrain
china militarily in the region
rob mcbride al jazeera tokyo